je m'engage à ce que cette opération ne
fait pas peser de menace du tout sur
l'emploi en france et ailleurs
après usine par usine dans le monde
c'est sûr que la charge de nos usines
dépend pas de nos succès commerciaux et
même si nous les souhaitons aussi bon
que possible
il arrive de temps en temps cueilli des
baisses de charges dans certaines usines
dans le monde donc sur les
restructurations l'idée d'une mini
chaîne non non non non il n'y a pas
encore une fois cette opération vise à
augmenter nos forces à augmenter nos
capacités et non pas du tout à
restructurer notre outil industriel à
québec avec nous ce soir le ministre de
l'économie pierre frébault se fait des
bonds soir millions les mots de monsieur
poupart lafarge est ce que l'engagement
pour vous il est suffisamment clair en
faveur des usines des emplois de la
pocatière de saint-bruno de se rétracter
a mon avis oui j'ai eu l'occasion de
parler avec mesure pour lafarge voit
même la semaine passée et il est clair
pour moi que ils voient l'opportunité de
l'achat de bombardier pour solidifier
leur présence en amérique du nord ce
marché qui est en grande croissance
comme on s'est longtemps en retard par
rapport à l'europe
d'une part ils s'engagent à créer un
siège social pour les amériques basée
dans le grand montréal
ils s'engagent à avoir un sens de
développement de recherche en est gêné
pour la motorisation des trains pour les
très adapté au crime au nautic et ils
s'engagent à bonifier l'emploi à sorel
tracy la pocatière sujet évidemment aux
contrats que nous pourrions avoir en
amérique du nord rue pour en voir
d'amérique du nord met pas à saint-bruno
nécessairement ses mots ces deux beautés
generis et un morceau alors que les
usines on y met ses plus sûrs ainsi la
pocatière la pocatière monsieur pour la
fage reconnaît qu' une expérience en
expertisant soudure et industrielles
intéressantes
alors écoutez suiveurs de contrôle plus
bord de l'emploi n'ont pas de garanties
mais un engagement de médecine alors
nakasone maintien d'un siège social
maison de recherche dans les
circonstances il faut il faut être
confortable que la structure
industrielle de
bombardier alstom est plus puissante que
boire du sol et je pense qu'on peut
conduire rapidement
alstom parle de 575 millions de dollars
de synergies
il ya 750 employés au siège social
nord-américain de bombardier transport
de saint bruno
qu'est ce qui va se passer avec ce siège
là et avec les employés étaient sains
mais ne s'est pas hissé social 755
beaucoup de services d'ingénierie déjà
qu'ils existent je pense que monsieur
par lafarge ou alstom veut bonifier ce
centre là le bureau chef des amériques
comme tel on a parlé un bégaiement
commence à se structurer il va avoir au
sens tant des chefs régionaux y voir un
chef canadien face entre les mains il va
aux recherches américaines qui auraient
des ressources sur un chef quelque part
en amérique du sud peut-être plusieurs
chefs un au mexique
mais là le siège social des amériques va
être basé à montréal
mais qu'est ce qui va se passer avec ses
imprudences et ça parce qu'il ya quand
même des activités administratives il
peut y avoir des doublons pour alstom
maintenant ce service nouveau mobilier
le bombardier transport société
allemande la très pratique et beaucoup
de services d'ingénierie à saint bruno
le bureau chef qui vont être créés voir
des nouvelles fonctions ils vont proma
s'appuie sur ce qui existe déjà aussi le
nom le nombre d'employés additionnel est
encore incertain et enfin franchement je
pense que j'ai la charge pour le faire
je le savais non plus à le sens est
important qu on est quand même la
direction générale soient ici alstom a
une usine qui on a parlé hier soir à
l'émission à hornell dans l'état de new
york on fabrique des trains pour un
tract là-bas usine très avancés sur le
plan technologique pourquoi est ce thème
investir et plus au québec et non pas
plus à onex il ya onze usines
américaines d'alstom sur le sol
américain
bombardier ou son usine aux états unis
je pense que c'est que je pense c'est ce
qui va arriver c'est que vraiment on
veut une force de frappe
ils veulent faire refaire pour le marché
américain leveaux marché et l'or et je
pense que monsieur legault employés
mener les discussions récemment avec les
gouvernants généraux de certains états
elle rêve de regarder une structure dans
american dans je pense qu'on peut offrir
aux américains
cette structure là et on peut bénéficier
en partie de contrats qui vont être
octroyés pour les américains mais
comment comment vinifier monsieur
festival pascal buy america act aussi
aux états unis ouais mais écoutez on
peut aider
des composants la pocatière et
versements les côtes canadiennes vont
être porteur seulement fait en interview
et au québec
je pense qu'il ya moyen de bonifier
l'offre les programmes tiers pour servir
tous les marchés en respectant les
règles bilatérales et vend des commerces
mais on peut avoir des wagons américain
qui a semblé en partie ou des morceaux
de tissu
la pocatière j'avais dit la semaine
passée qu'il fallait regarder vers le
futur
parce que regarder leur passé quand on
regarde bombardier s'est un petit peu
décevant n'est ce pas à tristan ce qui
s'est passé ce que vous êtes convaincu
que bombardier avec les ventes des
derniers jours est une entreprise plus
solides pour l'avenir raconté c'est sûr
que le québec
on est désolé un bombardier en regardant
l'histoire
c'est un animal à quatre pattes on avait
brp à l'époque vous vous rappelez un
avion commercial l'avion d'affaires
elles ont encore brp quand même ben
j'arrive alors je pense qu'aujourd'hui
je pense que peut-être c'est révolu de
voir gallas une structure industrielle
mondiale d'avoir un
car à quatre têtes c'est complexe
aujourd'hui ce chacun des métiers
tellement de seraing
moi je pense qu'on regarde les 4
l'opération mon verdict l'époque on a un
fleuron québécois qui est brp un valeur
boursière de 6 milliards toi mes
employés on a maintenant bombardier
résiduelles qui va être quand même un
champion du monde de sa catégorie
les avions d'affaires l'adour bosser le
maire avion qui va le présenter en
affaires le challenger le plus vendu
l'année passée on a onze mille employés
on a une valeur boursière je savais de
quoi même sans être plusieurs milliards
sont aussi dans le deux fléaux québécois
qui vont être maintenus dans la 2 200 m2
par la semaine passée je vais pas vous
répéter on n'a pas pu converser doivent
airbus et bombardier a moins bon je
m'excuse à moi de jouer en fédérale ait
voulu mettre beaucoup d'argent sur la
défense ces deux militaires comme les
américains ont fait avec boeing comme
les britanniques les allemands et les
français fait pour airbus on n'est pas
sur nous donc là de son armée peut pas
vivre en soi et les trains je pense que
la structure industrielle de la samba
qui permet d'avoir pour le québec
je pense à un horizon très florissant
oui sans aucun doute je comprends mais
dans une économie de propriétaires comme
vous comme monsieur legault et vous
l'avez et beaucoup évoqué la au cours
des dernières années des derniers mois
c'est les japonais mitsubishi
maintenant qu'ils sont propriétaires de
ces énergies c'est les européens de
toulouse qui sont propriétaires de la
220 et puis alstom les français alstom
qui sont propriétaires de bombardier
transport on s'éloigne de cet objectif
qu'on a d'être propriétaires de nos
grandes innovations
je pense qu'on peut faire les deux je
vais raison je pense qu'on peut
cohabiter avec des investisseurs
étrangers qui vont donner des gares
donneurs d'ordre comme airbus parce
qu'on est chanceux d'avoir airbus ohwawa
220 de regarder des vagues au bélier
autobus lien on peut faire des camions
en train de faire des autobus
électriques je pense qu'il ya une
nouvelle génération de sociétés
il avait entièrement raison le focus du
gouvernement c'est d'avoir des sociétés
québécoises des pyrénées avec moi mais
ça n'empêche pas en parallèle d'avoir
dérobé y étrangères qui reconnaissent en
passant l'avantagé de simpson va pas
chez bombardier sont faibles et ils sont
heureux d'avoir des gens compétents et
la de 120 passionnés mais zalio membre
monsieur guillon fourie qui on est et si
jeudi à montréal
si vous êtes avec monsieur legault dit
fier d'avoir hérité de cette opération
alors je pense qu'il faut en être fier
aussi
michel nadeau nous disait dernière
question qu alain bellemare n'avait pas
vraiment réussi finalement à redresser
l'entreprise parce que on visait 20
milliards de revenus en 2020 un cash
flow des liquidités positif d'un
milliard on est quand même très loin de
ça comment vous évaluez le travail de
monsieur bellemare depuis cinq ans et
que j'ai pas la prétention de voir juste
de me bellemare tout ce que je veux dire
que je parle pas de défendre non plus ce
que je veux dire c'est que j'ai du sang
à face à une pensée là les joutes année
ses deux mains dans le dos et difficile
la dette de bombardier présentement
avant le remboursement qui va se faire
avec les transactions et 2,9 milliards
peut être plus ou moins de neuf
milliards 2,7 milliards qui vient du
cseries
il ya deux milliards qui vient du lit 85
à dire qu'il vaudra jamais donc 9
milliards de dette sur des projets pour
lequel bombardier n'aurait eu aucun
retour économique alors disque en partie
de maisons d'avoir une hypothèque sur
une maison avec ceux construits
consultant je pense que ne pas défendre
monsieur bellemare contrat mais je pense
qu'il faut quand même regarder
youri t d'une situation n'était pas
facile de faire mieux peut-être et je
pourrai pas de juger c'est la preuve que
le post industrielle bien on s'arrête si
monsieur fatiguée bien merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup merci